[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEAN MA: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Data
Analytics 309, where
we're going to talk about
advanced techniques in Cloud
Dataprep for cleaning your data.
Quick show of hands--
quick show of hands,
how many people
here are familiar
with Cloud Dataprep?
Show your hands.
OK.
A good number of you.
Sorry, I can't see, because the
lights are right in my eyes.
So today will definitely
be an advanced session.
We're going to talk about
some of the more challenging
techniques in Dataprep.
But we will start off with
a brief overview of Cloud
Dataprep, just to
level set everyone,
make sure everyone's
at the same point.
The main focus will be talking
about the Dataprep lifecycle
and common challenges we've
seen with our customers.
And then we'll talk
about specific scenarios
and advanced techniques
to solve them.
As part of this,
we'll, of course,
be interspersing demonstrations
live with my co-presenter.
And then at the end,
we'll do a brief recap,
as well as, if we
have time, some Q&A.
Brief introductions.
Sean Ma.
I'm the product manager
responsible for the Cloud
Dataprep.
I've been with it since
the very beginning.
And with me is Cindy Sood.
She's the Dataprep sales
engineer for North America.
And we're both from Trifacta.
So as you know,
Google and Trifacta
have partnered for
the last few years
to provide you Cloud
Dataprep as a service,
and it's part of their
GCP big data suite.
Together we've got thousands
of joint companies,
tens of thousands of users,
and millions of Dataprep jobs
running all around the world.
You may ask the question,
who is Trifacta?
We're an industry leader
in data preparation,
as recognized by
analysts and customers.
And more importantly,
together with Google's
server-less platform and
Trifacta's easy to use
interface, our goal
is to make-- is
to help you get the most
value out of your data.
OK.
Enough with introductions.
We'll do a really quick
overview of what--
where Cloud Dataprep
is, and then we'll
go into those scenarios
I talked about.
So I'm sure everyone
here at Google Next
has access to tons of data.
Right?
It's coming in all the time.
You probably have too much
more data than you can handle.
The key question
though, of course,
is gaining insight
from that data.
Right?
Regardless if it's
marketing data, IoT data,
machine learning training data.
How do you get
inside all that data?
So Cloud Dataprep
is specifically
designed to solve this
challenge by providing you
data preparation as a service,
where you can visually explore,
clean, and transform
any type of data,
whether it be semi-structured
or structured data, you name it,
you'll be able to work with
it in an easy to use interface
without having set up
any infrastructure,
install any VMs, or
manage any systems.
Right?
Our goal is to make
data preparation, which
typically takes weeks, takes
weeks and a lot of effort
to do, into something that
takes days, if not hours.
And of course, we want to make
this as accessible as possible
to a wide range of users.
So there is data scientists, who
I'm sure in the audience, data
engineers and data
analysts, we want
to make sure that
everyone can use
data preparation without
having to write any code.
All right.
So how does this work?
Very briefly.
So while our first cover
is on how we access data.
So Dataprep has native
integration with your GCP
project through IAM.
And so it allows you
to access data directly
in BigQuery and
Cloud Storage, or you
can upload your own files.
So that way you can use
a self-service interface
to then transform, profile,
cleanse, join any of your data
that you need.
Now, when it comes down
to actually executing
this at scale, Cloud Dataprep
uses the power of data
flow in order to easily
and efficiently scale
to any region in the world.
The last thing I'll
note is that once you've
got the data
prepared and refined,
the question is, where
do you want to put it?
And often the downstream
systems that you'll
see here on the analyze side
are going to be BigQuery.
You can load it in there
for additional querying.
You can use it for BigQuery ML.
You can obviously build
reports and data studios,
so that's often an
end result for this.
But, just as often,
you're loading
into Cloud Storage
where you might actually
use it as in Cloud
ML to train a model.
So these are different--
they're very high level-- how
data comes in, how
it's transformed,
and where it goes once
you're done with it.
Last slide from the
introduction is,
when do you use Cloud Dataprep?
What use cases is it good for?
Now, don't get me wrong,
clean prepared data
is going to be useful
in many cases, right?
Who doesn't want to use that?
But we found in particular
that many of our customers
focus on three particular
use cases where
they're most successful with.
The first one's data onboarding.
This is where
analysts in particular
need to deal with third
party or external data,
and they want to integrate it
into their existing pipeline.
But because it comes
from a third party,
it doesn't always conform
to their internal standards
in certain formats, so it's
actually hard to use and hard
to automate.
So how do you get
that standardized fix,
so that you can use it inside?
Next is data science and
machine learning, right?
So this is not
just for analysts.
All right.
Oftentimes, data scientists
are using our Dataprep,
because if you want
to train your model,
you really want well--
you want well-structured,
clean data in order
to be most efficient
with these projects.
And the last one is
marketing analytics.
Probably most folks
are familiar with this.
You've got lots of marketing
data that's been generated,
especially in the Google Suite.
But oftentimes you want
to gain additional insight
from that marketing
data by combining it
with data from other
departments, sales, finance,
support.
So in order to join the
data, aggregate it, pivot it,
all those analytics
that you need,
in order to get
the most out of it,
you often need to manipulate
and transform the data as well.
In all three cases, Dataprep
is designed specifically
to help you with
these three scenarios.
All right.
So that's enough of
the intro, now we're
going to get into the
meat of it and we're
going to talk about
common challenges
that customers really have faced
during the Dataprep lifecycle.
What we'll do is I'll
go through the scenarios
and kind of give you
an overview of that.
And then we'll
switch over to Cindy,
who will actually give you a
live demonstration of each one.
So let's start off with
the Dataprep lifecycle.
This is just a quick
diagram for that.
Starting off on the left here.
You're starting
off with raw data.
The goal is then to discover
what's inside of it,
so that you can structure
and clean the data, right?
And then clean the data, remove
obvious data quality errors, so
that you can then go
to the enrich face,
where you're combining it,
joining it, aggregating--
basically transforming
the data to what you need.
Following that,
then you'll validate
it to make sure it conforms
to your organization's rules
and definitions.
And ideally, this whole thing
goes into an analytics--
downstream analytics,
like I said,
Data Studio or ML
initiative from there.
Now, you might notice, this
is a very iterative process,
and that's intentional.
So you can do the whole thing
through the Dataprep interface,
where you're kind of
going through this
and cleaning your data,
preparing your data
to the point where--
to exactly what you need,
exactly with your standards.
And the goal here is for
you to do this yourself.
And you can do
this really rapidly
without any additional help.
Now, of course, once you get
that data into that format
that you need, you
can then automate it,
you can fully automate it,
and you can schedule it,
so it runs periodically.
So now you've
empowered your pipeline
to run without you being
there and just updating,
and your downstream systems.
So that's the high level
Dataprep lifecycle.
Now let's get into the
challenges associated with it.
These ones are
specific scenarios
that we've seen with
customers in different phases
along this journey.
So let's start off
with the discovery
and structuring phase.
And while it's really nice when
the data is in perfect rows
and columns and no
issues up front,
very often you get
semi-structured data or even
unstructured data.
And those things, in order
to get any value out of that,
you actually need to access
the individual elements
and dig into it from there.
So that's the first type of
problem that we'll be tackling,
how do you handle that
kind of nested data.
Following that, as part of the--
after you've structured
the data and you're
going into the
cleaning phase, you'll
often find that the
data doesn't necessarily
have the right format for
what you're looking for.
Often it's actually a
slightly different pattern
you're dealing
with in your data.
And again, it's
very hard to make
use of data that's all
of different formats,
of different patterns
inside of it.
You want to standardize
that, or you
want to normalize that
into something standard,
so that you can actually, again,
perform your transformations
and cleanse it.
And next is on
the cleaning side.
While you can apply
common data quality rules,
removing nulls, checking for
statistics against the data,
you may also
encounter situations
where humans have
entered the data,
so there's issues with
the entry of the data
that it just doesn't
fit any pattern.
It's really hard to figure
out what those things are.
So this is actually before
you start doing pivots
and joins on things, you
want to actually make sure
that that data is cleaned
up and standardized.
From there, what
we'll do next is then
talk about validation
of the data.
So remember the
whole goal of this
is to make sure that your
data is ready for analytics
or downstream modeling.
But how do you know your
downstream system will actually
accept your results?
All these systems have
very specific schemas
they're expecting, expecting
the data in a certain pattern
order.
How do you ensure that that
is actually going to work?
And of course, if you
want to automate all this,
you have to make sure that
thing's working consistently
and working each time.
So these are the four challenges
we'll be talking about.
And we'll use the following
scenarios to talk through them.
The first one is going
to be understanding
nested data, where
we'll show you
how to unpack and
extract information
out of deeply nested elements.
Next is normalizing
data patterns.
We'll talk about profiling,
understanding those patterns,
and then converting
them into a standard
that you're looking for.
When we talked about
inconsistent data,
we'll show you something
new with Dataprep
around clustering and
standardizing your data.
And the last one,
validating results,
we'll show you how to compare
and match against your end
target, so that you know
what you're generating
is actually going to be
successful in your end system.
All right.
So let's get started.
I'll cover the first two,
nested data and data patterns.
And then, like I
said, we'll actually
demonstrate some of these.
So thinking of nested data,
all right, often users
start off with
nested file formats.
So JSON, AVRO, XLSX, PQT.
That's just the
starting part of that.
So let's take a look at
what this looks like.
I hope no one can read this,
because this is actually
really painful to understand.
It's got a lot of wonderful
information on it,
but it's really hard to use,
really hard to understand,
really hard to get
any value out of it.
So and what's furthermore,
even if you found a way
to parse it, OK, let's parse
this, this is fairly easy,
JSON, just parse
it, you're still
left with these type of
elements, complex data
elements, often seen as
arrays or key value pairs.
Now, this happens,
not just in the files
but this also
happens in BigQuery.
I'm sure many folks are familiar
with nested fields in BigQuery.
You'll see this type of
data nested inside of it.
So you'll still
encounter an issue
where, hey, after I've done the
first level of understanding
the data, I need to
go deeper than that.
And finally, even if you
get to individual values,
let's say, for example, I get
to the search reference here
and I get to my
individual value here,
well, really, you don't want
to access the whole thing,
you actually want to get access
to some of the embedded values
inside of it.
This clicker's slightly off.
So what you want to
do is you actually
want to extract specific parts.
In this case here, you're
looking for the search
term that was actually used.
So that's an embedded case.
So once again, it's
still nested data,
even though you're down
to the individual value.
So how does Dataprep
handle this scenario?
Well, first thing out of
the box, Cloud Dataprep
supports those
various file formats
and will immediately show you
that data in a row and column
format.
So you immediately see
these elements here.
I'll show-- point at this.
The elements here--
the customer--
you'll see them as
individual columns.
You'll also see the data
types automatically inferred
in the case where you
have nested values,
this key value pair here, you'll
see that automatically show up
here, and then the rest of the
data broken out from there.
Now, the nice part about this
is that, because Dataprep
has understood this
as a nested value,
it actually can help you inspect
the contents by simply clicking
on it and you'll
be able to see--
you'll be able to see
a nicely formatted--
you'll be able to see the
individual elements nicely
formatted.
So this is important
because, hey, this
is information I'm
looking to have
and I want to actually use
this for my transformations.
So very easily you
will be able to decide,
do I want expand this as rows?
Or I expand this as columns?
This case, I kind of want
to unnest this and expand
this as columns.
So just one click and
then I can just unnest it.
And immediately it becomes five
columns in my same data set.
So now you can perform your
aggregation, your joins,
whatever you need.
Now, this is a scenario
where I actually
wanted to expand it out.
But funny enough, a key trick
is that not all your data
is relevant.
One of the hard
parts of nested data
is that then there's a
lot of data inside of it
and sometimes it's all garbage,
or a lot of it's garbage,
and expanding and
unpacking all of it
may be a waste of your time.
It may be slow, actually
may cause more confusion.
So there are times
where you actually
want to be much more
specific about the data
that you extract out.
So I showed you an example
where I did expand it out.
But let me show you
one now where I have,
once again, I have these
key value pairs here--
so this is a sale
[INAUDIBLE] line.
I've got some interesting
information inside of it.
That's great.
But I don't need all this.
I really just want product
key, and let's say, total sale.
So what you can actually do as
part of the bar chart up here,
Dataprep allows you
to actually select
those individual
elements, the things that
are highlighted in green.
Just select the
elements that you need,
and you can actually tell
Dataprep just to extract those.
And it'll just produce
those two columns.
So you don't need to
expand everything and just
kind of blow out your data set.
Just get the things
that you need,
because you can see
what's inside of it.
Other things you can
do with nested elements
is that you can actually
perform metadata operation.
Sometimes you might
ask the question like,
how many elements are
in this nested value?
And you want to use
that in your data.
You can also perform
those operations directly
on these objects.
The last one I want to show
is just talking about those--
getting that substring
of information.
So in this example
here, I wanted
to grab that search term--
I wanted to grab
that search term.
So what you'll see here
is that all you have to do
is highlight the data
that you're interested in,
so you interact directly
with it, highlight it,
and Dataprep will automatically
suggest a transformation
that extracts it out for you.
So you don't have to deal
with the whole string,
you're just dealing
with what you need.
All right.
So now we've got our
data expanded, extracted.
Let's take a look
at the data itself.
And when you're
dealing with data,
when you're looking at the
individual parts of the data,
you're probably looking at
patterns inside of it, right?
And I'm sure everyone's
familiar with these.
These are pretty
standard examples.
But of course, it depends
on your geography,
depends on where your data
is from, that these standards
apply, right?
And problems arise when
you have data coming in
from different
places that you're
combining and
joining and blending
and they have different formats.
You can't use it.
Like, if these things
are-- it's going
to be confusing if
you try to combine
these things in the same
data set because they're just
different values.
So the problem, of course,
is that parsing this, even
identifying these patterns
inside your data is not easy.
Everyone here familiar
with regular expressions?
Who loves regular
expressions here?
Just by a quick show of hands?
All right.
So you don't need
to be here for this.
Thanks, bye.
For everyone else, this is
going to be a challenge.
This is going to be a
challenge to not only identify
the patterns that you
want, but even then,
can you imagine how do you
convert all the patterns
into a standard that you want?
You're going to be dealing with
multiple regular expressions
on that.
So the nice part is
that Dataprep actually
handles this--
actually has more built in
tool specifically around data
patterns.
What you see here is
Dataprep taking a column,
and you can see additional
column details here
for a selected column.
Not only does it tell you
it's data quality up top,
it tells you unique
value and distribution,
but down here it
actually breaks out
all the pattern combinations
that are within the data itself
and shows you the cardinality.
So now you know what's in it
and how often does it appear.
This is super useful,
because then you
can figure out which format
do you want to standardize
the data on, which
format do you want
to normalize and put things on.
In this case, although
the majority of the data
is in year, year,
month, day, I actually
want it to be in month, month,
day, day, year, year, year.
So that's kind of what I want.
So it's as simple as
clicking on the pattern
that you're interested in
and you'll get a suggestion
for transforming that data.
That automatically takes
all the patterns here,
converts all these other
value patterns here
into the pattern
format that you want.
And all the syntaxes handle
them under the covers.
So no regular
expression for you.
So sorry-- whoever-- the
few people who wanted
this, no regular
expressions for you.
At this point, it's probably
enough of me talking.
You probably want to
see this in action.
So I'm going to hand it over
to Cindy, so she can show it
to you in the product.
CINDY SOOD: All right.
Thanks, Sean.
So here we are in the
Cloud Dataprep home page.
And under my Recently
Updated Items,
I'm just going to choose
the Sales Data Flow.
When I do that, it takes
us into a flow view.
And think of the flow as
a project and just a way
to organize your work.
I've already registered a
data set here in this flow.
I can select it to see more
details over here on the side.
So we'll see that this is a
JSON file and it resides in GCS,
and there's additional
metadata here as well.
Now, I've already started
doing some transformations.
So I have some transformation
logic in my recipe
that's attached to the data.
We're going to choose
to edit the recipe
and we're going to add
more transformation logic.
When we do that, were
brought into what
we refer to as a
transformer grid,
and you're presented with
rows and columns of your data.
Now, I want you to
keep in mind, when
we looked at the details
of that data set,
it was a JSON file,
remember that?
And do you notice how
Dataprep has automatically
unnested the file format into
rows and columns for you?
That's pretty cool.
We've also done some really
other great things too.
So you're also presented with
the profile of your data.
So we do that with these
bar charts and histograms.
And that's for every single
column that you have.
And we also give you
this quality bar,
which is kind of nice as well.
And this is based on
the inferred data type,
that Dataprep will infer
a data type for you when
you load data.
So we're going to give
you a quality bar that
will tell you how many
valid or mismatched values
you have present.
So what's the first
thing you notice?
There's a big red flag
in this data here.
So the first thing I notice
are these red sections
of the quality bar,
so it's saying,
come, take a look at me,
there's something wrong here.
So, for an example,
under Currency Key,
my data type is
inferred as an integer.
Now I can show that
I have valid values
present by the green
section of that quality bar.
And then I have mismatched
values present as well.
So this tells me that I
have some data in here
that's actually not an integer.
So it flags us and it's a
really nice visual cue to say
there's issues with the data.
To deal with that, I'm
just going to click on it.
So you can interact with these
histograms and the quality
bars.
And when I do
that, I'm basically
interacting with the data.
So when you interact with the
data, what we're going to do
is we're going to come up with
these predictive interactions.
So Dataprep has a predictive
interaction engine.
Based on your interaction and
the data you're looking at,
you're going to get these
suggestions over here.
The first suggestion that I
get was to delete these rows.
I don't really want
to delete these rows.
What I want to do is I want
to deal with this data.
So I'm going to come down
here to this set suggestion
and I have this set
suggestion that says,
set the mismatched
values to zero.
When I choose it, I get
a really nice preview
before I actually add
that logic to my recipe.
So it helps you
make decisions on
whether this is something you
actually want to do or not.
So this is fantastic.
So I actually do want this,
so I'm just going to hit Add.
You see a nice cleaned up
quality bar right here.
And that logic is
added to my recipe.
Now, you can also
interact with the bar
charts of the histograms, as
well as interacting directly
with the data.
So here I'm going to select
this comma in my customer name
because I want to split out the
last name from the first name.
So all I have to do is
interact with that comma.
Again, I get
suggestions over here.
I get a split suggestion
as the first one.
The first suggestion is just
to say, OK, any delimiter,
but I'm going to specify
the comma as the delimiter.
Again, we get a nice preview.
This is exactly what I want.
I'm just going to add that.
Now we're to come over here
to the sales order line.
Now, this is a bit trickier.
So here the data
type is an array.
Now, an array in Dataprep,
as many of you probably know,
is just a list of items
or a group of elements.
I'm going to expand
to look at this.
So not the prettiest thing.
To help visualize, I'm
going to search my rows
just for an open curly bracket.
So when I do that, I can see
the start of each element,
or each item in this array.
So this is really helpful
because I can visualize it.
But what I really
need to do here
is inspect the information
that's associated
with the sales order lines.
And I have to get each of
these individual elements
into their own unique row.
So that's really easy
to do in Dataprep.
All I'm going to do is come over
here to the sales order line,
select it.
Again, we do get some
details over here
about the data, as
well as suggestions.
I'm going to come down to
this flatten array values
into new rows.
I'm going to select that.
It says convert arrays in
the sales order line to rows.
And what that does, and
you can see in the preview,
is it's going to
take each element
in that array, those
lists of items,
and put it into its own rows.
And I did it with just
the click of a button.
And you can see all
of these elements
from that list put
into their own row,
as well as all of the other
relevant data associated
with that row is populated.
So I'm just going to add this.
It's exactly what I want.
I'm going to add
that to my recipe.
You come back to that column,
we have a new data type.
We have an object.
The object is basically
these key value pair.
So you can see that because
you can expand the data
and you can see all
of these keys here
and all the values
associated with the keys.
Now, as Sean had
talked about, we
don't want to extract
all of that information.
I'm only interested in a couple
of items within the sales order
line.
So what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to extract just a couple
of these key value pairs.
And to do that, I'm going
to come to the histogram.
I'm going to select this
bar chart that represents
the product key,
and then the bar
chart that represents
the unit price.
We get a nice preview.
The suggestion, of course,
is to unnest and create
new columns for these keys.
So the product key
becomes the header,
and the unit price
becomes the header.
And then all of the values
associated with those keys
are now populated in your rows.
It's exactly what I want.
I'm going to add it.
And now, basically, I have
expanded my data, the rows
and the columns, by just
flattening and then extracting
the relevant information.
So now I'm done pulling
out the information
that I'm most interested in.
SEAN MA: That
looked really easy,
just half a dozen steps or so.
CINDY SOOD: Well, Sean, if
you were paying attention,
you would see that it
was only two steps.
SEAN MA: My bad.
CINDY SOOD: All right.
I'm going to continue
with this data,
because over here
in the order date
I see that I still have
some mismatched values,
and I need to finish
prepping my data.
So, again, I could just
select this red section
to see what's mismatched.
You then are-- you're
given all of the rows.
When you select that,
it's going to highlight
all of the rows that
are mismatched value.
And I can kind of visually
see right here that I just
have different date formats.
So what I really want
to do with this column
is to get everything into
the same date format.
Again, it's pretty easy
to do this in Dataprep.
I'm going to select that column.
Over here, those details again.
And then we have this section
that's called Patterns.
Now, I can choose to
show pattern details.
Will give you these
patterns right here.
It will tell the number of rows.
And then you get a little
sample of data as well.
So I actually want to go month,
day, day, year, year, year,
year.
I'm going to choose
that pattern.
Now, again, I just
interacted with the data.
I get these suggestions over
here on the right panel.
The first suggestion
is keep rows.
That's actually
what we're seeing,
but I'm going to come
down to this convert rows.
And if you look
here, it's converting
values like these three that
I don't want to that one
that I actually selected
in the patterns.
So three to one in one step.
So I'm going to hit Add.
And when I do that,
this gets updated
with the standardized
format that I selected.
Pretty nice.
So I was able to
profile, identify
the pattern of interest,
change it, and then validate,
because if you look now, we
have that quality bar here
and it's all valid values.
So that's the end of the
first part of the demo.
We're going to go
back to Sean and he's
going to talk about
a couple more.
SEAN MA: I think there
were two people here
who were sad you didn't do
regular expressions, so--
CINDY SOOD: Oh, no.
You want me to have a headache?
SEAN MA: OK.
So we're moving on to
the next two examples
with inconsistent data
and results validation.
We just covered patterns.
So what the hell's inconsistent
data supposed to mean?
Well, that's
actually specifically
data that doesn't really
conform to any patterns.
So quick example here of--
here's a company that, of
course, humans have entered--
ACME Inc. You have slightly
different variations
of the data.
You see one with
periods and a hyphen.
I think spell checker kicked in
and just renamed this to acne.
And then we've got
nice formatting,
got bolds and quotes that
you have inside of this.
So while we can all
recognize this is probably
all the same company, not
so great for your data,
and not so great if you're
going to do analysis on this.
So it's really hard
to pick this up.
Of course, the goal has
then standardized this
to a single
established value, so
that you can make effective
use of joins and aggregations,
because you do want ACME Inc to
show up four times as one time
as opposed to four
different companies aside.
So this is something
new that we've
added to Dataprep
recently, is the ability
to cluster your data into groups
based on clustering algorithms.
This is something we released
just a few weeks ago.
And in this example here, what
you'll see is that we have
several different clustering
algorithms that will grab
the data-- that will
access the data--
that will take the
data in a given column
and show to you how
many rows show up
in a-- for a given instance
of that data, kind of group
them all together for you.
There are different
ways you can group
the data, based on comparing
values, closer spelling,
sometimes pronunciation.
And that's really important,
because the trick to all this
is that you don't want to apply
just one algorithm when you're
defining your
groups, you actually
want to apply multiple
algorithms on this.
The reason why is you
want to capture as many
of these inconsistency
as possible,
so you can standardize them.
So for example, apply
additional algorithms
on this, multiple of them,
and you'll see more come out.
This one I applied--
was pronunciation,
so you'll see things
like acne and acme.
These pronounce
similarly, so you actually
want to include them
into your group.
It just makes
things a lot easier
for you to then standardize
it and go forward from there.
You can type in what you
want your end result to be.
Now, all this said,
wonderful algorithms
that we are constantly
making better and better.
It's never ever
going to be perfect.
So one of the nice part of being
able to interact with the data
and actually see this
is that you can now
also identify when there
are exceptions to the rule.
So now, as an example,
where the clustering,
because of the pronunciation,
it captured one too many.
In this case, I was just looking
for BB Construction, but not
Bibby Construction.
That's not what I wanted.
So you actually will be
able to go into Dataprep,
select that exception,
just highlight it and say,
I don't want to include
this, so I can still
standardize on everything else.
So it also captures
exceptions in addition
to the standard set.
So now we're at a
point where we've
gone through most
of the challenges,
we've addressed the
structured and formatted data,
we've made sure that
we've cleansed the data,
you've probably performed
a bunch of transformations,
a bunch of transformations to
pivot the data, apply formulas.
The last thing we want to cover
again was the data validation.
How do you know that
what you just built
is actually going to
be useful downstream?
So when it comes to
the target, you'll
often see examples like
this where the targets have
a very well designed schema.
This is an example
of a BigQuery table.
Everyone's familiar with this.
Columns, data
types, constraints.
Pretty standard in
that regard, right?
And most of the time, when
you're preparing data,
you probably have a good
sense of what you're
looking for, you're going to--
manually compare, or you're
going to remember it off
of memory, what you want.
And you decide, OK, I think
this is what I wanted.
I'm going to go ahead and
publish this to, again,
I'm going to use
BigQuery in this example.
And oops, BigQuery
greets you with a very
specific and accurate
error message.
And while it's got all
the information you want,
it's actually very difficult
to parse and figure out
what went wrong.
You might be going
back and forth
trying to figure out,
well, what's wrong
my Dataprep, what's wrong
in the BigQuery table,
and you kind of want to go
back and forth between the two
and figure that thing out.
I will note that, while you see
this error message in BigQuery,
you see the same problem
with files as well.
It's actually kind of worse,
because they don't tell you
what the scheme
is supposed to be,
so you won't find out until
you kind of pass along
and you get bad data.
Well, the good thing
is Dataprep allows
you to do this comparison
much, much more easily.
And you achieve that
by comparing the data--
comparing the target directly
in the data set itself.
So what you can do
is you can actually
import the target here--
import the target here
directly into a data set,
and it will automatically
align against the data
that you're working with.
So you can do that
direct comparison
and see samples of the data,
understand what that is.
This comparison is really
useful because then you can also
get these indicators
that tell you, hey, how
well have things matched up?
So green indicating things
are very well matched up,
that's exactly
what you want, blue
indicating that there's
slight mismatches
that you want to
address, red indicating
there's something very--
something significantly wrong.
And the last part about this
is, because now Dataprep
knows what you want
it to look like,
it actually can
suggest transformations
to help fix this.
So in this case, I'm going
to fix the effective date.
I'm going to click
on that, and it's
going to tell me,
oh, the problem
with your effective date is
that your formats are incorrect,
instead of--
you want to change it from day,
day, month, month, year, year,
back to year, year, month.
Great.
That's what I want to do.
So it's as simple
as clicking on it,
and it will
automatically fix it.
Now, there may be cases where
we're dealing with Y data sets,
where you're dealing with
potentially hundreds of--
sorry-- Y data sets, potentially
hundreds of columns across.
In that situation,
what you can do
is switch to the
column view of Dataprep
and it allows you to more
compactly see just the columns.
It's much easier to reorder,
rename columns on mass.
You can also decide to remove
columns or add missing ones.
And the whole goal,
of course, is then
to make sure everything
matches, everything's
good to go in green, and
validate this in the product
before you go ahead
and publish it
before you set your automation.
All right.
So let's now see this in action.
Cindy.
CINDY SOOD: Great.
Thanks again, Sean.
Waiting for our
screen to come up.
There we go.
So I am back in Dataprep.
And I'm in the transformer grid.
And I have a different
data set here.
And this is actually--
it resides in GCS.
And it's recently
uploaded customer data.
So it has some information,
like their first name,
their last name, their
account number, some employer
information and many
other fields here.
Now, what I need to do with this
is I need to take this data set
and I need to append a customer
details table in BigQuery.
So before I do that though,
I know I have some manually
entered data here, so I have to
do some column standardization.
And I need to do that
on this employer column
because I have lots of
different company names here.
And I'm sure you can imagine
some of the challenges
with this manually
entered data if you're
going to do some aggregations
and you don't have
a single standardized value.
So I'm going to come
to the employer column.
We're going to go to
this drop down menu,
and we have
standardized right here.
So when I choose standardize--
I'm just going to show you
where that clustering option is.
We run the first cluster to
look at the similar strings
across all the rows.
So we're clustering
all of the rows
based on characters in common.
So here with Acme Inc I see
I have 10 different values.
So Acme Inc written 10 different
times across 53 different rows.
And that's really quite
a problem sometimes.
So I mean, there
are things here--
it's not just like
capitalization,
but it's also hyphens
present, commas present,
periods present--
people who embellish their
company name when they're
inputting it themselves--
the quotes here.
So I want to get all of
these to the same value.
To do that, I'm going
to select them all.
We'll come over here.
I'm going to enter my new value.
Make it kind of simple.
Now, before I apply
this, Sean talked
about running another
algorithm, so we're
going to come back to
the clustering options,
and we're going to now cluster
values based on pronunciation,
so all of the rows that
actually sound alike.
And when I do that,
what do you see?
We actually have a
few more rows show up.
Now, the nice thing here
is all I have to do is come
and click on these.
And as I select them, the
value, that standardized value
that I want is
automatically put in.
It's that simple.
I'm now going to hit Apply.
We're now going to choose to add
this logic to my recipe step.
So you can always come
back and look at this.
And when we come back
to the transformer grid,
the recipe opens up.
And we now have
this reusable logic.
So, anytime we have
new data coming in,
we can actually use this logic
that we've already created
to do exactly the same thing.
So that's pretty nice.
Now, if you remember what we
want to do with this data set,
so we've done our
standardization,
is I want to now
run a job, and I'm
going to append that BigQuery
table, the Customer Details.
So I'm going to come here,
I'm going to choose Run Job.
And I already have my
publishing action set up,
so append BigQuery,
the Customer Details.
I'm going to run this
in US-West is fine.
And I'll hit Run Job.
OK.
Look at what we have here.
Something's not happy with
this, so we can't run the job.
So what I've done is--
I only paid attention
to the data.
What did I not pay attention to?
I didn't pay attention to
the schema in BigQuery,
so I need to fix that.
So I'm going to cancel.
We'll close out of this recipe.
Now, I have the schema
over here in BigQuery,
so what I could do is
I can come down here,
I can look at the schema.
Just scroll down.
Or not.
They've changed my
resolution on the screen.
So there's a schema down here.
Here we see account number.
It's an integer.
So we'll come back to Dataprep.
And, OK, here's
the account number.
Here's the integer.
Or it's a string though,
so I'd have to change that.
So I could go back to BigQuery
and I could try and look
at that schema again.
Here we go.
And then back to Dataprep.
Well, that's kind of clunky
and not really a lot of fun.
I don't really want
to do that, especially
for a really wide data set.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to load that target right
here in my transformer grid.
So I'm going to attach a target.
I'm going to look for my
customer details, target
schema, and I'm going to add it.
So that's pretty nice.
This is right from BigQuery.
This is the table
that I want to update.
And we're going to give you
a sample of the data as well.
And we give you these visual
cues to help you get your--
this source data to the
target schema that we want.
Now, we also have a
column view, which
is super helpful when
you're looking at wide data,
it's a bit more efficient.
So I go to the--
I just clicked on
this column view here.
Over here is our target.
Over here is the source.
Again, we have
these visual cues.
The first position
is the account number
and it's an integer.
When I hover over
this blue box here,
it's telling you there's
a matching column.
I can move it, and it will
show you in the source
where that column is.
So watch real close.
I just selected that blue
box and it automatically
moved that account number.
Does anybody notice
what else it did?
There's a big hint.
It automatically changed
it to an integer for me,
so I don't have to go
in and do any of that.
So now I'm just going
to continue down.
City-- we have all of these
matches, which is fantastic.
This is so easy.
And then we come down here and
we have this contract start,
and it's a red box.
Now, if it doesn't automatically
detect this for me,
I can choose what column.
And I know I have
this column one--
I actually know-- I can see
the data type is the same.
And I happen to know
it is the contract
start, so all I'm going
to do is scroll down
and select that column one.
It automatically
renames it for me,
and we have a nice alignment.
Now I have two extra columns.
So this is why I got that big
error in addition to that one
data type difference.
I'm just going to select these.
Again, I'm interacting
with the data.
I get these suggestions
over here on the side.
I'm going to come down to
the delete columns, because I
don't want it.
I'm going and choose Add.
We'll go back to that grid view.
Close out of this recipe.
And nicely, I can validate
against my BigQuery table
before I actually publish.
Pretty awesome.
Now I'm going to run the job.
Again, we're appending.
US-West is fine.
We'll hit Run Job.
All right.
So it's going to run the job.
I've easily
standardized the data.
And then I quickly
use that target schema
that we loaded into
the transformer grid
to get my source data ready
for publication into BigQuery.
So that covers the second part.
SEAN MA: Well, that
looked like fun.
All you were doing was
just kind of clicking
and it automatically
transformed everything for you.
CINDY SOOD: Yeah.
Kind of like a video game.
SEAN MA: All right.
So now we'll just wrap
up coming to the end.
Very quickly, we'll
cover the topics--
just takeaways from
what we just covered,
and I'll talk a little
about some of the next steps
that you might be interested in.
So if we remember, we covered
four topics, four challenges
that we're going after.
First was nested data, how do
you expand and extract values
from that nested data.
And so we saw examples of that.
Following that, when you're
dealing with data patterns,
take advantage of the
column profile details,
and then use the
suggested transforms
to actually fix those formats.
You don't have to write
everything from scratch.
When it comes to
standardization,
use multiple algorithms, build
that group as much as possible,
so you get the widest set.
And the last one to note
is, when it comes down
to publishing, before you
do that, quickly validate
it, make sure that your data
actually matches your target
and hopefully it can solve
a lot of the minor details
that you need in order
to make it successful.
These were just a few of
the powerful techniques
and transformations that
are available in Cloud
Dataprep that help you gain
insight inside your data
all through a simple
easy to use interface.
We didn't have a chance
to talk about some
of the sharing and
automation capabilities that
are a part of Dataprep,
so you can build out
and maintain your pipeline.
But if you're interested
in learning more,
we do have a booth here.
It's between the server-less,
the analytics and machine
learning zones,
where you can ask
Dataprep experts any
questions that you may have,
as well you can sign up
for our training workshop.
We do these things in person.
And then lastly, if you
want more examples, things
that you've seen outside
here, please take a look
at the Dataprep community.
And one last part, it's
for the folks who actually
haven't tried Cloud
Dataprep and were just here
just as an intro, you can try it
today, just go to your console
and just launch Dataprep
directly from there.
It's in the big data section.
And with that,
thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]